this is to hussein reading for reviewer
richard wakeling variety is writer's
republic strength not just in terms of
the multitude of extreme sports on offer
but also in the sheer breadth and
diversity of its environments one minute
you might be shredding down the
treacherous slopes near grand teton
national park's high's peak while in the
next you're paragliding above a 1 000
foot tall rock formation as lay ukulele
girls's horrid cover of gangster's
paradise provides the soundtrack there's
so much to see and do and no one would
blame you for recoiling at the sight of
another massive open world ubisoft game
featuring a sprawling map littered with
dozens and dozens of icons yet ryder's
republic never feels as overwhelming as
other open world games it's not quite as
chill as steep developer ubisoft annes's
previous game but it has a similarly
hands-off style that rewards you for
playing how you want
whether that means challenging yourself
only partaking in certain events or
anything else in between the choice is
entirely up to you riders republic
consists of five careers bike races bike
tricks snow races snow tricks and air
races if you don't like any of these
activities you don't have to do them and
the game doesn't punish you for skipping
them you might not fancy strapping a
rocket-powered wingsuit to your back and
using it to skim cliff faces in the name
of winning a race and it doesn't matter
if you're only interested in hurtling
through a verdant forest on a mountain
bike narrowly avoiding trees as you go
riders republic will still keep
rewarding you with new events and
unlocks in that specific corner of the
game this freedom permeates throughout
every inch of the rest of the game too
from each snow-covered slope to every
oily gear chain in order to progress you
need to earn stars with each event
rewarding a single star just for
completion whether you finish in first
or last place this feels like a strange
decision at first since it seemingly
robs the game of any stakes or sense of
competition this casual approach might
suit you and that's fine but for anyone
who's after a challenge or an incentive
to outperform the rest of the field each
event's optional objectives provide one
giving you another way to earn
additional stars in the process these
objectives might ask you to win a race
on the highest difficulty level rack up
a specific score during a trick event or
collect balloons scattered along the
course some of these are relatively easy
to achieve while others are
significantly harder and challenge your
skill level whether you engage with them
or not is once again up to you there are
enough events and stars to go around
that you're going to progress and unlock
more either way so it all comes down to
how you want to approach the moment to
moment gameplay there's a subtle skill
ceiling at play as well although
writer's republic is more concerned with
serving up unabashed fun than anything
else you can turn off assisted landings
to earn off more xp when performing
tricks but this is primarily about
adding another degree of difficulty than
anything else leaving it on lets you
perform outrageous tricks without having
to worry about manually aligning your
character before they crash back down to
earth thus affording you another degree
of freedom in how you approach this
extreme sports adventure
finding the best lines through corners
or limiting your air time during races
are other techniques you can deploy to
try and out maneuver the competition but
this kind of attention to detail isn't
entirely necessary each of the sports
are relatively easy to pick up and play
and it regularly taps into the primal
thrill of heaving yourself down the side
of a mountain to get your heart pumping
right as a republic's exhilarating sense
of speed is a crucial component of this
too ensuring that you're perpetually
glued to the edge of your seat as you
teeter on the edge of disaster with
every passing millisecond of course the
game world also plays a pivotal role in
how enjoyable it is to slalom between
trees and over vast stretches of desert
the map is composed of seven u.s
national parks all crammed into one
beautiful and impossible space you can
instantly jump from yosemite valley into
sequoia and then bryce canyon with each
region offering different surfaces
obstacles and breathtaking vistas for
you to soak in there's a tranquil
pleasure in foregoing the brash
corporate sponsored events and embarking
on your own excursion pedaling through
the arid wilderness of canyonlands
crunching the untouched powder in
mammoth mountain's snow-capped village
or swirling above the clouds in a
wingsuit
the calmness is offset somewhat by
writer's republic's chaotic multiplayer
the map is always populated by hundreds
of other players sometimes they're real
other times they're ghosts but it's
impossible to tell so it doesn't really
matter stop to take in the scenery and
you'll see a cluster of bikers wearing
giraffe costumes saunter by or watch as
a snowboarder plows into a mound of snow
after a failed trick attempt it's
disappointing that you can't do more
with these random players since
multiplayer races are confined to their
own separate mode but it does create a
constant social presence that makes it
feel like you're part of something
bigger this all comes to a head in the
hourly mass races which cram up to 64
players into one pulsating mob of
downhill races there's just enough
collision detection to make these races
clumsy and erratic but that's part of
their charm mass races are hectic
completely ridiculous and represent
ryder's republic at its multiplayer peak
you can also take part in regularly
sized races and trick events with other
people but these matches are unbalanced
to the point where they're not
particularly fun each player takes their
own gear into an event that has its own
gear score similar to the division 2
except with skis and wingsus instead of
assault rifles and shotguns a higher
gear score generally means whatever your
riding is going to be faster there's no
restrictions on gear in multiplayer
races so being left behind by players
with snowboards 200 points higher than
yours is a common occurrence that saps
away the thrill of competition
[Music]
while ryder's republic's presentation is
pleasantly bright and colorful it's also
accompanied by incessant and horribly
cliched dialogue
wow slap me with bread and call me a
sammich you've just qualified for fox
racing mountain rush this is a gnarly
mass race starting from the frozen ice
of teton down to the trees in yosemite
this is all in service of a paper-thin
story that doesn't need to exist just
imagine if ssx tried to give you a
reason for why you're hurtling down a
mountainside with a piece of wood strap
to your feet but competing at the
invitational
it's a transformative experience man
transformative
trust me
i know
i was there 10 years ago i'm 12.
sucky there's value in saying nothing
but rioters republic would rather plague
your ears with annoyingly cross dialogue
until you're tempted to mute the audio
altogether this also isn't helped by the
main hub area where all of these npcs
hang out being a gross focal point for
microtransactions for all of the freedom
in writer's republic player
customization isn't included on the list
you earn money throughout the game which
can be used to purchase new clothing
items but you're restricted to only a
few per day since they're on a rotation
while the rest of the store is populated
by more elaborate gear that's locked
behind a real money currency this might
be par for the course but it doesn't
stop it from feeling off these are
unfortunate blemishes on what is
otherwise a fantastic game riders
republic is a thrilling approachable and
incredibly varied extreme sports game
featuring an awe-inspiring open world
that impresses with both its scale and
diversity there's nothing else quite
like it and while it's too talkative for
its own good there's a sprightly energy
to the whole thing that makes it easy to
recommend for anyone seeking an exciting
adventure
[Music]
[Music]
you